- So step number one for avoiding
the collapse of civilization
is: try not to cough on one another.
(audience laughing)
Okay, so this is a virus
and disease epidemics caused
by microbes like this,
viruses and also bacteria.
These are the things that
precipitated the fall
of the Roman Empire and of
the Golden Age of Athens
and of most of the empires
of the Native Americans.
And it's sort of surprising
that when you look at the largest threat
to the survival of civilizations,
it's something so small.
And in fact, it's so invisibly small
that viruses and bacteria
weren't understood
until very recently in history.
And yet, despite their small size,
these have caused more
death and destruction
than all the famines
and wars put together.
So take as an example, smallpox,
which was the most destructive
disease in history.
It's killed hundreds of millions of people
between ancient times and 1977
when it was finally eradicated.
The Romans lost up to a
third of their population
and parts of their empire,
and about a millennium later,
what happened is the crusaders came back
from pillaging distant lands
and they brought an epidemic
of smallpox to Europe,
Europeans then went over to the New World,
they brought smallpox to the new world,
and in doing so devastated
the Incas and the Mayans
and other natives there.
And some of you may know
in 1707, smallpox wiped out
a third of Iceland.
So similarly the Black
Plague, yersinia pestis,
this wiped out a third of
Europe starting in 1347
and then it kept coming
back to haunt Europe
century after century.
Yellow fever, so badly decimated
Napoleon's armies in Haiti
that Napoleon gave up the idea
of having a Western French empire
just because of yellow fever,
because of this 22,000 crack soldiers
that he'd sent to Haiti,
21,000 of them died.
And so he gave up, and
that's why Napoleon sold
the Louisiana Territory
to the United States
because he finally, he said,
"I just don't wanna be running this show,
"confronting diseases that
I no longer understand."
So he sold it for roughly 5 cents an acre,
which in a bloodless manner
doubled the size of the United States.
Okay, and so it goes on and on.
There are these viruses and bacteria
that have really navigated
the course of history in major ways.
And when I'm gonna suggest
is that the internet
is really our key to survival here.
And this is for three reasons,
first, what the internet gives us
is the ability to work remotely
and when you can work
from home telepresently
what this allows you to do
is inhibit viral transmission
by reducing face-to-face
contact, the human-to-human contact.
So in the face,
(audience laughing)
so here's the idea, the next time
that there's a really
killer virus coming our way,
if businesses are prepared in advance,
what they can do is really
leverage telepresence
to keep supply chains running
with the maximum number of
employees working from home.
Now this isn't gonna keep
everybody off the street,
but it's gonna vastly reduce the density.
And it turns out that when
it comes to epidemics,
that's all you need to do,
you just need to get things
below a tipping point.
So the reason viruses have
this sort of tipping point
is because viruses have a limited lifetime
and a certain probability
of infecting somebody.
And so if you have very low host density,
then the virus dies before
it can get to a new host.
But as soon as you get
enough people together,
then it can find new hosts
and you go from some
sort of equilibrium state
into an epidemic, it really blows up.
And in fact, you can see
this sort of thing happening
every Christmas holiday season
with people shopping in the malls
because they all bunched together
and then you cross over this
population tipping point
and then everyone gets flu and cold.
Okay, so now here's the problem.
In the past, societies
have reacted to epidemics
by bunching together.
So, for example, in medieval Europe,
when the Black Plague hit
and other plagues like it,
warring religious factions
who spent all their
time killing each other,
would show solidarity in
the face of all this death
by marching together
in the streets together
to show that the Catholics
and the Protestants
could be friends in
the face of the plague.
Well, that was a real
misstep in terms of density.
And it turns out that the Native Americans
in a show of goodwill, they
would gather in the tents
of people who were infected with smallpox.
So everyone would gather
together and again,
unfortunately that was a gesture
that was sort of ill-fated.
And so this is exactly the fear
that all major medical centers have.
The next time we have a
major new strain hitting us,
whether it's avian flu or
swine flu or something,
the big fear that medical centers have
is that everybody with a cough
is gonna come flocking into the med center
to get checked out, and
this is really dangerous.
And so I think this is the
second great opportunity
afforded to us by the
net besides telepresence
is telemedicine whereby with increasingly
sophisticated technologies,
we don't have to have patients coming in
and bunching up together,
but instead we can have
diagnosis from a distance.
Okay, so the telepresence
and the telemedicine
are very useful because they
keep the population density
below a tipping point.
I think there's a third benefit
that we get from the internet,
which is we can optimally direct resources
when there is an outbreak.
So you may know that the
Center for Disease Control
tracks the flu by tracking
what happens at the local hospitals.
Now the thing is, it takes
two weeks for the CDC
to put together their report.
It lags the actual flu
outbreak by two weeks.
So Google came up with a better idea.
And what they do is
they track where people
are searching for terms
related to the flu.
So if they're searching
for information on symptoms
or medicines or something,
it turns out that over
the course of the nation,
that serves as an excellent proxy
for where there's a flu outbreak.
So while the CDC's
report lags by two weeks,
Google's lags by only a day.
So this gives us a very rapid way
to know dynamically
exactly where the flu is
and where the outbreaks are happening.
Okay, so unlike previous generations
that were brought down by disease,
especially because they
didn't know how to react
in terms of density and sparseness,
we can now do better
because of the internet.
If we're well prepared when
the next epidemic arrives,
we can fluidly shift
into a self quarantined
telepresence society in
which the microbes fail
by dint of host sparseness.
And so there's a lot of talk of course
about the ills of social isolation
and everybody sitting on Facebook.
But whatever those ills are,
it bodes a lot worse for the
microbes than it does for us.
So although we're well into this step,
there's work to be done if we
want to save our civilization,
businesses really need to work
on developing their disaster plans
and their work from home epidemic plans.
I wrote a paper on this
in the journal Nature
about five years ago
and I've been watching as
businesses have been doing this,
I've been monitoring sort
of how this is going.
Some businesses are doing
it, most aren't still.
It's really important to try
to get businesses to do this,
and it's extremely easy to test, right?
To work out the kinks by having
everybody work from home.
And then the second thing as a society,
we really need to keep
developing telemedicine
and similar ideas like that.